ah the women's March praised as the
biggest activist protest in modern
American history home to celebrities
like Rihanna Amy Schumer Charlize Theron
Madonna I have an awful lot about
blowing up the White House this crazy
person nasty like my blood stains on my
bedsheets we don't actually choose now I
know it's become popular to film radical
social justice warriors and paint modern
progresses with a broad brush but that
wouldn't be fair
I wanted to accurately capture today's
liberal mainstream and we're better to
do that and the biggest progressive
gathering ever smash the patriarchy so
remember now this is mainstream
liberalism today now seeing the crowd my
producer not gay Jared and I realized
that we needed a disguise to blend it hi
I'm Stephanie with all the frequencies
of a feminism and I am here at the
Women's March and often to march for
progress and equal rights which are
human rights and we're just going to see
what they're marching everything we're
going to see what happens and and see
what's most important moving forward
under the trump administration
and in genell's here for moral support
she you don't seem to know a lot in
videos they're supposed to come in
faster oh the perfect cover we quickly
found out that nobody questions
criticizes nor runs security background
checks on [ __ ] even high-profile
politicians
yep that's actually Wendy Davis but
we'll get to that in a second with
Stephanie and Janelle we could get away
with anything go anywhere act any way we
wanted and we were really able to learn
what today's progressive issues are all
about and regardless of our anti-racist
work we are also every single day
both benefiting from and participating
in white supremacy so your wife's comin
IMO bites of and I know feminists should
be effectively liberal feminist killjoy
all the time it seemed in particular the
women demanded an end to misogyny and
sexual objectification by focusing
entirely on their
why the king I even got to meet why what
are we most the man behind a woman not
the woman behind the man the man behind
the woman as it should be
contrast that with this man who got to
hang around topless women all day by
simply claiming he was gay right you got
game son play today yeah equal rights
this guy gets it yes these women prove
their point through fighting against
patriarchy by showing their breasts
I could buy a four-dose yet they're not
they're not it is exactly what we don't
want
now with Trump coming in and the threat
of tyranny as they put it equal rights
we're certainly on the mind so Stephanie
and Janelle wanted to find out exactly
which rights were most in peril but as
far as policy what should we all be most
concerned about with this March with
Donald Trump and this administration
[Music]
you like the rights specifically to your
community or in general the imminent
challenges that are I don't like
projected or forecasted for the country
and the overall like biggest concern for
me is just this idea that this
administration has a right to tell any
of us what we can do with our bodies
right we can wear on our bodies right
what we can say about our bodies right
okay and that is our choice not theirs
and it's not theirs to tell we can we're
certainly not fashion advice from Mike
Penn no it seems the only people who had
anything close to an answer were these
two don't make it a felony have an
abortion they want to put people in
prison for abortion yeah see I didn't
know about this but that was pretty
stupid so to get clearer more definitive
answers we decided to go straight to the
top headlining speaker and de facto
feminist leader of the Democratic Party
Wendy Davis is such an inspiration what
rights do you think people should be
most concerned about and how they can be
active with this incoming administration
Oh skunked again no answers here either
[Music]
important missions going forward every
place we see the trampling of our
quality right we all need to rise
together and
for each other not in our separate
spaces now separate interest but
understanding that each of us
particularly a strong final question oh
no no right there I thought for sure my
cover had been blown but I forgot
progressives aren't allowed to ask
logical questions regarding [ __ ]
even linebacker sized ones with facial
hair because tolerance
now even though senator Davis had no
answers for specific rights being
infringed upon she did have an economic
plan to empower women across the country
outside the boundaries of this country
the sighted weeks ago that in support of
women marching in states everywhere they
were going to make called
he had economics that's right okay so
explain that really quickly we women
when we earn money
that's true financial economy let's give
it to people are gonna spend it okay now
if this seems confusing let me clarify
wendy davis former senator noted DN c--
feminist has created an economic
platform based entirely on the negative
stereotype that women are fiscally
irresponsible shoppers spending women
spend so much more you want to keep them
it's an economic thing that's not so
what did the world's biggest feminist
protest teach us well not much mainly
that sexual objectification is bad
unless women do it tits are fun bras do
legitimately suck not cage air it's a
surprisingly good kisser and Donald
Trump wants to infringe upon women's
rights but we're not exactly sure which
rights something something something but
see but what did we accomplish well not
a whole lot either but we felt good
about ourselves it felt good to go on
down to the protest take part and
showcase these people for the insane
folks that they are hey I guess we have
more in common than we thought hey if
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside